c'est le pire des scénarios le rejet de
l'accord sur le break site remet tout en
question pour les britanniques installés
en france et qui travaillent c'est le
cas d'amy cette anglaise
mariée à un français a fait sa vie en
bourgogne aujourd'hui elle le sait tout
va devenir compliqué pour elle mais
aussi pour sa famille
moi je suis vraiment très inquiet à toi
parce que en fait ça fait quinze ans que
j'habite là sans problème et là je me
retrouve à faire les papiers pour la
préfecture en faire une carte de séjour
éventuellement faire un passeport
français et ça fait 15 ans que je le
finis tranquille et d'un coup tout
change des papiers indispensables pour
ne pas se retrouver en situation
d'illégalité sur le sol français
cette situation plonge également nicolas
grant dans la plus grande incertitude de
nationalité écossaise
il a tout quitté pour venir travailler à
dijon j'ai choisi de vivre en france ma
femme est française nous voulons
construire notre famille ici et vivre
ensemble les conséquences pour moi après
mars
je veux rester ici monde je ne sais pas
du tout si ce sera possible
rivée à son écran d'ordinateur le
délégué régional de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie franco
britannique
lui aussi est inquiet devant la chute de
la livre sterling
une réalité depuis déjà deux ans d'antan
à la chambre que dans ma société
nous avons pris déjà des mesures en
suivant les consignes de l'ambassade du
royaume uni c'est à dire de demander à
tous les britanniques d'aller demander
une carte de séjour
un seul espoir pour eux l'acceptation du
plan b qui doit être présenté lundi par
theresa may